japanese journalist kenji goto first he
was kidnapped by Islamic state
terrorists in Syria than in 2015 he was
decapitated the pro-russian journalists
ollas Bosnia in April 2015 he was shot
in kiev by a sniper driving past in
mexico protests after the murder of
ruben espinoza for a long time now
Mexico has been a dangerous country for
journalists a total of 110 journalists
were murdered in 2015 in 67 of the cases
the journalists were specifically
targeted for their reporting while 18
more died while performing journalistic
work in Syria in woo Regent you don't
expect the state really to to get
involved in the safety of journalists
unfortunately but in those countries
where there is still a government
interstate in place we do expect that
these countries make sure that
journalists can work freely and without
fear of violence in France an attack on
the Charlie Hebdo magazine came with a
clear message journalists expressing
critical opinions must fear for their
lives even in Europe and in Egypt three
journalists from al Jazeera were held in
cages during their trial because they
exercise their right to freedom of
speech they were sentenced to several
years in prison we think one of the main
means we can achieve that is to put into
place a special representative for
journalists with the UN the United
Nations he will then work with the
states and the nations where donors have
to fear crimes against them in their
work a UN representative might be able
to investigate why people who murdered
journalists for simply doing their job
are almost never brought to justice